[Music]  let's get started here's tonight's top  story  Mariah's night out in New York and new  details on her inspirational  transformation the singer showed off her  epic slimmed down last night if she  helped induct Jermaine Dupri into the  Songwriters Hall of Fame he knows how to  get you where you need to be to make the  best record sometimes life-changing  music for me Bryan and Jermaine work  together on hits like always be my baby  and we belong together  [Music]  mean Wallis or South et today that  Mariah is the happiest she's ever been  we're told us due to several reasons her  weight loss the end of her relationship  with her former manager and relief from  revealing her struggles with bipolar  disorder although her team has never  confirmed it sources tell ET mariah  underwent gastric sleeve surgery late  last year according to one report she  has lost 50 pounds so gorgeous how are  you feeling feeling good jolly  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]